nous ne pouvons pas diriger ce gars, nous devons rejeter
ce dont nous avons besoin d'altitude non, nous ne tirons pas
les poignées d'éjection à la seconde où je vous le dis,
d'accord, je suis bien le bienvenu et euh,
félicitations, bienvenue aux 95èmes
Oscars,
nous l'avons fait, vous avez réussi
tout le top  Les 10 films les plus rentables
cette année étaient des suites ou des franchises,
disent-ils, Hollywood est à court de nouvelles
idées. Je veux dire, le pauvre Steven Spielberg a
dû faire un film sur Steven Spielberg,
félicitations Stephen, tu sais, Tom et
James Cameron ne sont pas venus ce soir, les
deux gars qui  j'ai insisté pour que nous allions au
théâtre je ne suis pas venu au théâtre
Rihanna est là Lady Gaga est là
merveilleux
mon Dieu même Elvis est dans le bâtiment
ce soir là il est
tu sais que c'est une soirée spéciale pour toi
nous euh pourquoi tu ne l'as pas fait  amusant, nous voulons que vous vous
sentiez en sécurité et, plus important encore, nous
voulons que je me sente en sécurité, nous avons donc mis en
place des politiques strictes et si l'un d'entre vous se met en
colère contre une blague et décide de
venir ici et de s'amuser avec, merci,
ce n'est pas le cas.  ça va être facile quelques-uns de mes
amis vont devoir s'en sortir
en premier tu vas devoir
passer par le champion des poids lourds Adonis
Creed avant de m'atteindre
tu te bats avec Michelle yo avant de
m'atteindre
tu allais  ayez
[Applaudissements]
pour avoir Spiderman,
vous devrez le faire, vous
allez devoir vous mêler à Fable
man, nous
voulons que vos discours soient émouvants, nous
voulons aussi qu'ils continuent à avancer, donc le discours
dure trop longtemps cette année, nous n'allons pas
jouer  tu quittes
le film rrr on va te danser
hors de la scène et l'Oscar te revient
merci euh
ma mère a 84 ans et elle est à la maison en train
de regarder maman
oh je veux juste un Oscar
[Applaudissements]
mon voyage a commencé sur un bateau  J'ai passé un
an dans un camp de réfugiés
et d'une manière ou d'une autre, je me suis retrouvé ici, sur la
plus grande scène d'Hollywood.
Ils disent que des histoires comme celle-ci n'arrivent que
dans les films. Je n'arrive pas à croire que cela
m'arrive, c'est le
rêve américain
[Applaudissements]
et l'Oscar revient à
Jamie.  Lee
[Applaudissements]
arrête, j'ai 45 secondes et j'ai promis à
Janet Yang que je ne le ferais pas bien parce que
je suis une bonne fille
pour tous les gens qui ont soutenu
les films de genre que j'ai fait pendant
toutes ces années, des milliers et
des centaines de milliers de personnes, nous venons de
gagner un Oscar ensemble
et ma mère et mon père ont tous deux été
nominés pour des Oscars dans différentes
catégories
Je veux juste un Oscar
[Applaudissements]
d'accord
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous sommes en fait ici pour  faire deux choses, la
première est de sensibiliser à l'
importance vitale d'utiliser une bonne
crème hydratante étrangère.
Andy en porte une tous les jours depuis
29 ans. Je n'en ai jamais utilisé de
ma vie, je suis
toujours aussi époustouflant, en gros, un scrotum.
J'ai récemment réalisé le film.  ours de cocaïne
et
sans effets visuels, voici à quoi
ressemblerait l'ours,
aucun réalisateur ne veut s'occuper de cette
royauté de Lift Me Up à part entière
Rihanna
[Musique]
oh ouais,
nous avons besoin d'amour et l'Oscar va aussi
partout où
ce fantasme est un  gamin d'avoir remporté un
prix et d'avoir critiqué tous
les professeurs qui nous ont mis en détention, mon frère et moi,
vous m'avez éduqué, vous m'avez
inspiré et vous m'avez appris à être moins
connard, à votre tour,
d'accord, ma sensation rapide à laquelle je n'avais jamais pensé
moi-même en tant que scénariste ou
conteur, je n'ai jamais pensé que c'était
assez bon j'ai des problèmes d'estime de soi je
dois remercier tout le monde oui alors euh
merci oh mon Dieu les gars, mon
syndrome de l'imposteur est euh à un niveau sans précédent et
l'Oscar va à
les femmes parlent
[Applaudissements]
euh merci à l'académie de ne pas avoir été
mortellement offensée par les mots femmes et
parler mais si proches les unes des autres comme ça
bravo nous avons eu le plaisir de voir les
performances des meilleures
chansons originales de cette année prêtes
[Musique]
merci  toi
Idris Elba et Nicole Kidman, lauréate d'un Oscar,
l'Oscar va à
tout partout,
nous voulons le dédier aux
mamans, en particulier à ma mère et à mon père, Ken
et Becky, merci de ne pas écraser ma
créativité lorsque je faisais
des films d'horreur vraiment dérangeants ou
des comédies vraiment perverses.  des films ou s'habiller en
travesti comme un enfant, ce qui n'est une menace pour
personne euh
mon incroyable sanjio si jamais tu regardes
ça j'espère que tu sais que euh tu ne devrais
jamais avoir à être à la hauteur des standards
ce n'est pas normal c'est un peu fou je le
ferai  je t'aime quoi qu'il arrive
et l'Oscar revient à
Brendan Fazer
oh mon Dieu,
j'ai commencé dans ce métier il y a 30 ans
et les choses ne me sont pas venues facilement
mais il y avait une facilité que je
n'aimais pas,
euh, je n'appréciais pas  à l'époque
jusqu'à ce que ça s'arrête,
je te suis tellement reconnaissant, bonne nuit
[Applaudissements]
et l'Oscar va à
Michelle yo
[Applaudissements]
merci
pour tous les petits garçons et filles qui me
ressemblent qui regardent ce soir
rire c'est la lueur de l'espoir  et
les possibilités et mesdames ne laissez
personne vous dire que vous avez déjà dépassé votre
prime,
merci, merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et l'Oscar va à
tout le monde,
c'est incroyable, il n'y
a pas de film sans notre
casting brillant et au grand cœur et  Crew Daniels, je
ne sais pas quoi dire, je vous aime les gars,
vous venez de gagner la meilleure photo, hé hé,
nous en avons assez dit ce soir, je veux juste
dire merci beaucoup à tout le monde
ici, vous m'avez tous inspiré, passez une
bonne soirée.  les gars, merci beaucoup, merci à
tous, bonne nuit, merci
d'avoir regardé,
merci
[Musique]